supongamos que tengo tres matrices a b y
c
y voy a suponer que veis son de
dimensiones digamos m por n y que a es
una matriz de k por m bien lo que quiero
hacer en este vídeo es ver si la
propiedad distributiva se vale para el
producto de matrices así que en realidad
me quiero fijar en el producto de la
matriz a por la matriz de más
muy bien
pues ve ve tiene la forma vamos a
escribirla como sus vectores columna de
uno de dos hasta
hasta ve porque tengo n columnas y cada
columna tiene m entradas muy bien hice
análogamente que es la matriz cuyos
vectores columnas son c1 c2 hasta hasta
c
perfecto entonces quizás recuerden estos
son columnas así que tienen una
extensión también vertical
pero bueno quién sería este producto
pues por definición esto sería a la
matriz a multiplicada por la matriz b
más la matriz c pero por definición de
suma de matrices la matriz b más la
matriz c
es simplemente sumar cada una de sus
columnas correspondientes eso en otras
palabras quiere decir sumar las entradas
por entrada muy bien así que quién sería
de más c pues sería la matriz con
columnas de uno más uno en primera
columna de dos más de dos
esa es mi segunda columna y así
continuaría hasta bn + c m tienen el
mismo número de columnas y todas las
columnas tienen la misma cantidad de
entradas porque son matrices de la misma
dimensión ok y esto quién es pues esto
es lo mismo que la matriz por definición
del producto de matrices esto sería la
matriz a por de uno más uno esa sería la
primera entrada del producto a por b 2
más de dos segunda columna del producto
y así hasta por dn
más cn casi no va a cabeza
voy a tener que mover tantito
a por bm hace en cada una de estas son
las columnas de mi matriz producto a por
la matriz b se noten que esto está bien
definido porque esta matriz la matriz
bmc tiene las mismas dimensiones que la
matriz de o que la matriz ce ésta
también es una matriz de gm por n ya a
es una matriz de k por m así que como el
número de columnas
es igual el número de renglones en vez
más el producto matricial está bien
definido ahora bien quién es esta matriz
de aquí pues georges e nosotros sabemos
nosotros sabemos que el producto de
matrices con vectores si tiene la propia
distributiva así que esa primera entrada
en realidad
en realidad la puede escribir como
por el vector de uno más a por el vector
c uno simplemente distribuyó a la matriz
a sobre este producto sobre esta suma
perdón bien y que hay de la segunda
columna pues por el mismo argumento la
segunda columna sería a por b 2 más a
por c 2 y así para cada columna lo voy
haciendo hasta llegar a la última
columna que sería a por la columna b en
el vector columna b n más a por el
vector columna c n
y eso sería esta matriz de aquí pero yo
que sé pues ahora lo que puedo hacer es
es decir que esta matriz es igual a la
suma de las matrices cuyas columnas son
a x b1 b2
hasta por bn
estaba por bm
más
más la matriz cuyas columnas son a
porsche 1 a porsche 2
y así hasta
por c n
bien pero quién es esta matriz de aquí
pues por definición por la definición
que usamos esta matriz es precisamente
la matriz a por b nuestra definición de
producto matrices era simplemente
multiplicará a por las columnas dv y del
mismo modo esto de aquí es la matriz a
por c así que esto es en realidad la
matriz ave más la matriz hace pero eso
que me dice pues eso me dice
a partir de esto y llegue a haber más
hace así que
por bmc
es igual a por ve más de porsche así que
las matrices tienen la propia
distributiva al menos por la izquierda
porque recuerden que el producto de
matrices no es conmutativo así que a por
la matriz bmc no es lo mismo que la
matriz b más por la matriz a así que
tendría que checar la otra dirección
muy bien así que ahora lo que quiero
checar es qué pasa si tengo un producto
de la forma de más ce por una matriz
quiero saber cuánto es eso porque
recuerden estas dos cosas no son iguales
pero bien que sucede pues a
pues a era una matriz de kpm y beige
eran matrices de m por m así que esto
sería una matriz de m por n por una
matriz de acá por m que no está bien
definido en este caso el producto no
está bien definido así que voy a hacer
para resolver eso para solucionar ese
problema es decir que ahora
ahora voy a suponer que estoy en el caso
en el que la matriz
es una matriz de gm por n
y las matrices b y c
dice son matrices de
k por m
y en ese caso este producto sí estaría
bien definido y vamos a ver tienes pues
tendría
de más por la matriz a sería lo mismo
que la matriz de c
voy a escribir a sencillamente como la
matriz cuyas columnas son la columna a1
la columna a 2 así hasta la columna
n recuerden que en este caso cambié mi a
por una matriz de m por n para que esto
estuviera habían definido bien y cuánto
vale eso
pues la definición de producto de
matrices me dice que esta matriz lo
pongo aquí al ladito esta matriz va a
ser el resultado de multiplicar además
por cada columna así que esto sería
además por el vector columna 1 la
segunda columna sería además por el
vector columna a 2 y así así hasta
llegar a demás c
por el vector columna a n
noten que ahora además de nuevo es una
matriz de k por m
es una matriz de acá por m la suma
preserva las dimensiones de las matrices
y esto es una matriz de m por n así que
de nuevo mis productos están bien
definidos bien entonces cuánto vale eso
de allí pues yo ya se lo vimos en algún
vídeo y si no es una prueba bastante
bastante directa así que se las dejo
como ejercicio que el producto de sumas
de matrices con vectores si tienen la
propiedad distributiva así que esto lo
puede escribir como b por a1
+ c por a 1
la segunda columna es perforados
más separados
y así así continuó hasta ahora en más c
por a m
perfecto muy bien
ok y ahora esto de aquí pues creo que no
los voy a sorprender en absoluto esto de
aquí es lo mismo que la matriz ve por la
columna 1 luego la siguiente columna
como depor a 2 y así hasta b por la n iv
a eso le voy a sumar
me voy a sumar
voy a sumar ce por a 1
separados
hasta
hasta sé por a en y es claro que si sumo
estas dos matrices me da la matriz de
arriba porque sería sumar las columna
por columna así que la suma de estas dos
matrices sería la matriz cuya primera
columna es b x aún no sé por a 1 la
segunda columna sería b por a dos más
separados esta columna de acá etcétera
etcétera
ahora bien quiénes son estas matrices
pues ya nos la vemos venir
esta matriz de aquí es sencillamente la
matriz b por la matriz y esta matriz de
aquí es sencillamente la matriz ce por
la matriz a así que esto es la matriz
vea más la matriz sea en otras palabras
en otras palabras lo que acaba de probar
es que además por la matriz a es igual a
depurada más c por a así que las
matrices también tienen la propiedad
distributiva por la derecha así que no
importa si estoy considerando esto o si
estoy considerando o si estoy
considerando estoy acá
la propiedad distributiva se vale solo
tengo que recordar que el producto no es
no es conmutativo así que la matriz a
por la matriz base no es en general lo
mismo que la matriz vez más por la
matriz